en este vídeo vamos a hacer un repaso de
los números complejos si ustedes ya
estudiaron algo de números complejos en
el pasado con esto van a desempolvar un
poco sus conocimientos además de que nos
ayudará a explicar por qué usamos
números complejos en ingeniería
eléctrica si los números complejos son
nuevos para ustedes los invito a que
vayan a khan academy y vean los vídeos
que tenemos sobre números complejos
estos se encontrarán en la sección de
álgebra 2
comencemos los números complejos se
basan en el concepto del número
imaginario j en ingeniería eléctrica
usamos jota en lugar de y porque usamos
y para referirnos a la corriente
j al cuadrado va a ser igual a menos 1
esta es la definición de j y con esto
nos referimos a un número imaginario es
un concepto muy útil para la ingeniería
eléctrica ahora con esta definición de
número imaginario vamos a definir un
número complejo que normalmente usamos
la letra zeta para denominarlo nuestro
número complejo va a tener una parte
real que llamamos equis y va a tener una
parte imaginaria que le llamamos j y la
j está explícita aquí esta es la parte
imaginaria de nuestro número y esta es
la parte real de nuestro número complejo
z con base en cómo luce este número nos
sugiere que probablemente podamos
graficar lo en un plano bidimensional
que le vamos a llamar el plano complejo
el plano complejo luce así vamos a
graficar dos partes la parte real va
aquí y la parte imaginaria va acá
la parte real va en el eje horizontal y
la parte imaginaria va en el eje
vertical y este es nuestro plano
complejo si yo tengo un número complejo
z lo puedo representar en este plano
básicamente así recorre una distancia x
sobre este eje y voy hacia arriba una
distancia y esto me va a dar un número
imaginario zeta ceta es la ubicación en
este espacio complejo y esta es una
representación de un número complejo
otra forma común de representar un
número complejo es dibujar una línea a
partir del origen hasta el punto z aquí
básicamente tenemos un radio r que va
del origen hasta la z y se mide con
cierto ángulo t está aquí en rojo
tenemos a raya teta y en azul tenemos a
xy allí estas son dos maneras de
representar exactamente al mismo número
z aquí puedo decir que z es igual a r
con cierto ángulo teta y ahora podemos
ver cómo pasar de r contenta a xy yen y
viceversa una forma de hacerlo es usando
trigonometría simple digamos que
conocemos a r esta distancia de aquí x
es igual al coseno de teta por la
distancia r r coseno de teta así que x
es igual a r por coseno de teta si yo
quiero encontrar la distancia y conozco
la r esta es la distancia y puedo decir
que es igual a r por el seno de teta y
es igual
r por el seno de teta si conozco a r&a
teta es así como obtengo a x y allí
ahora veamos el lado opuesto supongamos
que conocemos x y xi y quiero conocer el
rey teta aquí tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo por lo que usó el teorema de
pitágoras r al cuadrado es igual a x al
cuadrado
y al cuadrado y si quiero encontrar el
ángulo theta voy a usar otro poco de
trigonometría la tangente es el lado
opuesto entre el lado adyacente el
opuesto entre el adyacente es entre x
por lo que la tangente de teta es igual
ayer entre x si quieren resolverlo en su
calculadora van a poner que teta es
igual a la tangente inversa de g entre x
aquí tenemos dos conversiones entre dos
formas diferentes de representar al
mismo número complejo queremos usar
estas conversiones y queremos pasar a
cualquiera de estas representaciones y
pasar de una a otra sin problema hay una
tercera representación que nos va a ser
bastante útil lo que voy a hacer es
tomar esta xy está allí y sustituirla en
esta forma rectangular de representar
acepta y nos queda que z es igual a r
por el coseno de teta y es igual a r por
el seno detecta voy a factorizar la r r
porsche no detecta con una jota en
frente escribo más jota porsche no
detecta si ven con cuidado esta
expresión de acá se dan cuenta de que
esto es una de las fórmulas de hoy les
puedo reescribir acepta como r por e a
la jota teta y a esto se le conoce como
la forma exponencial de un número
complejo qué significa todo esto
esto es exactamente lo mismo que esto y
esta es una de las dos formas de
representar a un número complejo así que
esta r por el a la j teta es este número
z es un número complejo que se encuentra
a un radio r del origen
y con un ángulo theta es a lo que nos
referimos cuando vemos ha elevado a la
jota por algo es una representación de
un número complejo esta forma nos va a
ser particularmente útil porque si
ustedes recuerdan cuando resolvimos
todas aquellas ecuaciones diferenciales
siempre nos gustaban las soluciones
exponenciales voy a resaltar estas
fórmulas que son las tres maneras en las
que podemos representar un número
complejo y todas son equivalentes y para
no olvidarlo voy a escribir que esto es
la fórmula de hoy leer
de ahí es de donde viene y por aquí
vamos a escribir el elevado a la jota
por teta es igual al cose no detecta más
j por el seno de teta la otra forma
tiene un exponente negativo es que a la
menos j porte está igual al cose no
detectan menos jota por el seno de teta
esta es la fórmula de hoy leer y en kant
academy tenemos vídeos de cómo llegar a
estas expresiones pueden buscarlas
ingresando esta palabra en el portal